[Musik]
das haben sie geschrieben
das ist super haben sie die bewerbungen
abgeschickt nein der text war nicht für
eine bestimmte bewerbung sondern nur
eine übung in meinem sprachkurs dann
wird es zeit dass wir die theorie in die
praxis umsetzen
sie haben jetzt hier eine
aufenthaltserlaubnis mit dieser
erlaubnis dürfen sie nicht nur in
deutschland wohnen sondern können hier
auch arbeiten oder studieren
sie haben die b1 prüfung bestanden und
wie ich das hier so sehe ist b2 auch für
sie gar kein problem
haben sie schon mal über die möglichkeit
nachgedacht hier zu studieren
ja aber sie wissen nicht was sie
studieren möchten den meisten serien
guten zahlen interessieren sie sich für
ein technisches fach
eigentlich macht mir kreative arbeit
mehr spaß
nun es gibt viele berufe in denen man
nicht nur technisch und mathematisch
interessiert sondern auch kreativ sein
muss vielleicht interessieren sie sich
für die arbeit im produktdesign oder im
social media bereich
mein vorschlag bewerben sie sich für ein
praktikum in einer firma dann sehen sie
ob ihnen die arbeit spaß macht okay ich
suche ihn mal etwas informationsmaterial
aus
dann kann man
heute schön
[Musik]